okay so the next class games of the week
so for this class i prepared
one uh
two games to be honest but uh but i will
probably have time enough for only one
game unfortunately
because very very complicated
and actually super interesting that's
why i
i don't think there will be enough time
including some you know puzzles for you
guys and so on
to discuss uh everything uh
audio game two in detail so probably
we'll stick with this one only
but we will see how it goes if there is
enough time we'll
talk also about the other one the game i
want to talk about today is
is from polish championships uh that
happened today
between uh wojciech miranda and radoswa
voitashak
very interesting game crazy crazy game
and uh this according to
i wanted to be to say actually a shout
out to wojtek
who said read the book that i wrote on
this subject and he analyzed this
version himself so thank you for getting
the book
and and i hope you like the rest of the
material here as well i'm glad it helped
you
in the game and uh yeah
okay so let's let's see what happened
e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6
bishop b5 uh spanish or
roy lopez a6 bishop a4 knight f6
short castle and bishop c5
what's the name of the book it's
modernized roy lopez
in two volumes um
in two volumes uh this this variation
bishop c5 are discussed in volume two of
the book
uh of those books so uh bishop c5
this is a molar variation
and this recently has become
extremely popular as well normally black
play here
a p5
not normally like other possibilities to
go for classical
uh are hanging bishop c5
and after a4 let's say rook b8 c3 d6
d4 bishop b6 and so on and on this
is big you know uh theory here
as well which is also the line i'm
talking about in the book in the book
here in this game bishop c5 uh however
happened which is
a very interesting uh as well especially
after the development of
you know the theoretical developments
that occurred in 2020
mainly due to games of
one game in particular and this is uh
dominguez versus caruana
and this game miranda versus watashik
actually followed this game up to a
point so we will see in a moment
what uh what happened so bishop c5
c3 b5 bishop c2 of course there is
possibility to
play bishop buffy as well it's more
solid more
less sharp and the bishop c2 is the most
critical
because the point is again here if black
plays b5 bishop b3 bishop c5
now bishop is ready on b3 has no
possibility to go to c2
so uh if black plays first bishop c5 and
we play
c3 now p5 now we have two moves right
now we have two squares for the bishop
so that's why bishop c2 is the most
principled
and the support is pawn and threatening
d4 so but on the other hand this bishop
c2 move allows move
d5 and this is of course the main
position of the entire line
and
yeah right now y has big choice really
really a big
choice there is possibility to play
[Music]
d4 there is move e takes d5 as well
there is move a4 which happened the game
which which i think is also the most
testing
i would like to show at first um
[Music]
what happened in my game uh versus uh
john ludwig hummer that in the play
against
2019 and
i lost unfortunately with white it was
mainly because
this in general this tournament i wasn't
playing well
uh because you know it was just
you know by some reason i played
horrible chess in the tournament when i
played against him
so d4 is the one the possibilities as
well after it takes e5
e4 knight takes d5 knight takes e5 d
takes c5
uh queen e7 this is another possibility
to play the idea is to
grab a pair of bishops and if white
grabs the pair of bishops uh you know
try and this should be generally good
but however in this position
black has very good counter play on the
light square especially the d4 d3 square
this knight can quickly get there
and objectively black is doing uh well
here i believe
well i can hop some chances of course
you can look for some ideas but
objectively
this is okay for black that's why a4
has become the main try here for white
and after detects e4 a takes b5
this is the way to go here with with
white
i talk about this variation in detail in
the book that i wrote
so i don't want to go you know like into
all the
intricacies here of what would have
happened if this if that
uh just want to give general idea uh
what's happening of course due to this
pin right now response on
impossible to take and knight is under
attack
and of course there are moves like right
now it takes f3
there are also other moves the move
hasn't been played yet i talk about
everything in the
uh in the book however the the most
testing was of course bishop g4
the the visual g4 to get to pin the
knight
with the queen pawn takes c6 and now
it takes uh it takes a free with idea of
destroying the portals destroying the
pawn stars around white's king
and hoping to create some attack against
white's king
on the other hand this gives white uh
material advantage of
like what a pawn so after g takes a
free you know white has extra pawn rook
hm
sorry bishop h3 very logical uh other
possibilities to play
bishop e6 which i think happened in the
game
if i'm not mistaken caruana versus unish
took some u.s championships
few years ago but this is not the most
critical here the best move is bishop h3
uh to hit the rug on e1 uh on f1 now
white plays rookie one
short castle and the critical move for
the entire line
is to play move here rook to a5 so idea
of rogue a5
is to put pressure on this bishop on c5
and pawn on e5
and ideally provoke this knight
sorry this bishop to go back to uh
d6 if this bishop would go to d6
then it would be you know sort of like
an achievement because
then bishop will be a little bit passive
and i talk about uh you know about
this line in the book as well and here i
bishop knight i think 93 simply very
very good move
followed by uh body of knight c4
in general white i believe i believe
that white is better in this position
so that's why because of that uh
generally
considering that white already sorry
black black already sacrificed a pawn
and second point is gonna be lost soon
pretty much
black should try to look for some uh
activity especially that white king is
exposed
so that's why in the modern you know
engines and so on
um suggest move queen d6 and the idea of
queen d6 is
also what fabiano played against lanier
dominguez
queen d6 b4 seemingly just loses the
pawn right because like
okay bishop goes back we simply rook
take player takes e5
and then after queen six even we can
play d4
killing this bishop uh you know bishop
comes
out to f4 g5 you know maybe queen d3
this is just uh winning for uh for white
uh why castle sucked the knight on e4
threatened queen g5
uh why castle here knight e4
well it's not so easy not so easy if you
if you're threatening queen g5 in this
position i can first of all
take the rook if you play queen g5 can
play a roux g4 cover
so this is the first and foremost and
here i think white is winning
but additionally i don't think it's the
only way to be honest because i can play
d4 myself right now which is i think
even stronger
because it doesn't uh still stops queen
g5
right so you don't have this mating idea
and your bishop is under attack knight
is under attack
and is pretty much about it i believe
and the game is just over i think white
wins
so nd4 is not uh doesn't it does not
really work
so coming back to what i was talking in
the game uh q6
before so yeah bishop b6 is not good as
i was saying so a visual basic is not
good it means that basically black needs
to look for
uh some very
dramatic i don't know or concrete ideas
so bishop takes f2 basically sacrificing
the piece
uh to destroy white's king even further
king's f2 e4 king g1 rook e8
you know e4 idea of queen h2 obviously i
mean i should slow down here with this
line because very complicated
e4 i just queen h2 obviously so it makes
sense to go back with king g1
now the beauty of this variation
in general is that there is no immediate
mate or
immediate attack against black white's
king but black simply throws a froze in
another piece to the attack
uh rook e8 with hoping to hoping to
continue the attack
but not and not try to mate right away
similarity will have
what i discussed in 95 a lecture in
grandmaster's choice
knight d5 idea was to put some
very big practical problems to
to to the opponent not necessarily win
right away here is pretty much the same
concept
so rook 88 uh joe rook joins the game
and now rook e3 has to be played uh
let me now go into details essentially
white queen
while queen is to bring the queen to the
defend here which is totally crazy of
course
and so on um but
knight g4 and the queen h2 well i'm
gonna take it
i'm not gonna allow you to play g9g4
so easily and here i win so you can't
play ng4 or someone
so after rugi3 the best move is knight
h5
knight h5
and you know he is he's just putting
knight under attack right but the point
is queen g6 is a big threat
uh and uh go will go after this king of
checkman on g2
or on f1 for instance this is not
possible right now because queen g6
king h1 queen g2 right or queen f2 of
king f2 queen
g2 and queen f1 checkmate so this
simply wins for black so white cannot
take the knight
but white should do what i should do is
to play a rook g5 is
bring their to the defense of the king
queen h6 f4 queen f4
and now this is this to be honest was
all played already this was there were
two games as far as i checked
um two games i think it
kedah versus quibble karov is one game
and uh
let me just uh yeah it was ikeda versus
qui bokarov
yeah actually i should step back for a
second f4 is there is a was the ikeda
versus kubo kharov
but in this position rook g3 was played
by elena dominguez and this was the
first game here that i would like to
show
and this is the very safe option but it
doesn't give any
advantage to white and in reality
black's position is very very
good here because this king still
remains bad after knight hg3 hdg3
it takes a free queen takes f3
now after rookie 6 position uh
wise position white's king is very very
shaky
both pieces are not still developed and
even though positions objectively equal
it is very difficult to play here with
with white i believe
and i think that black has a better from
practical point of view black has better
chances and this
this is in the game dominguez caruana
followed queen f4 which
[Music]
was made by g5 queen d4
uh rogue d6 and the queen e5 rogue e6
queen for d6
fabiano was happy with a draw here but
lanier dominguez had to play for a win
with queen e4
and he eventually went on losing the
game because uh fabian played rogue f6
with after uh afraid of rook f1 so
bishop d3 has been played and now bishop
f5
and this with and black has i think very
good initiative here
because again those pieces are not
playing and
this king is still still very very weak
so that's what happened in this first
game in this
variation so the next game
that happened here was a queen h6
and uh right now f4 so this is also also
what uh
what happened in this game miranda
versus voitashak so
f4 the the idea is to
slow down a little bit the white sorry
blacks initiative
and sort of close up the sun
the king side because after move like g3
you so you see like let's say pawn takes
everything is getting opened right
so if we play f4 we at least make sure
that
these rooks are not easily coming to the
game so
uh f4 is the move
and now knight takes f4 and now i buy y
has two moves either
rook two g3 back this one or this one to
g3
both are very interesting in the game
ikeda versus qui bokarov i think it was
rook eg free
and um
sorry rookie gg3 sorry my bad and right
in this game
voyage miranda played rook to e rook e
to g3
both moves are extremely testing both
moves are extremely
uh you know interesting for
to play for a win i analyze both in the
in the book so for uh you can refer to
that uh whenever
uh you know you have a choice
because both lies are just crazy i go
there in detail about all of it
so uh in the game here happened through
eg fridge is also of course
very interesting f5 rook takes g7
uh quintex g7 uh black should generally
give away the queen for the two rooks
and with idea of taking those groups
away
and weakening further black's king a
white's king king to g7
so and now uh uh miranda played queen e1
so after queen e1 this is the critical
position
so uh after queenie one
the person is totally crazy obviously
it's like no doubts it's so
obviously crazy position uh
totally imbalanced white has a queen and
a piece
for two rooks and
if white manages to get all those pieces
right
this bishop and from siwan knight from
b1
why will be winning white will be
definitely
winning however it is not so easy to do
that
because black has but first of all black
is on the move
and black can definitely put some
pressure against
white's king one and the best idea i
think right now in this position is to
play move
rook to f6 and this is what
also i think miranda said in the
um the commentary after the game the
rogue f6 was the best move i totally
agree with that
with it as rook f6 i think leads to
a very uh crazy position again
uh after rook f6 the threat is of course
rule g6
and it this king is
in big big trouble so after uh
queen e3 for instance which is king f2
uh
miranda whatever suggested right now uh
rook to g4 and again this is exactly
what i also analyzed the book
and the position is absolutely
absolutely
crazy black has i think very
good compensation for the uh for the
peace
is for the queen i mean and and the
peace so
and because this king is just so weak
and there are all sorts of ideas
against this king that black white or
the black can try
and uh it is not easy for uh for white
to you know find a move and the point is
that essentially
right now everything is well defended
for black and zero can
simply maybe join the game at some point
with strengthening the attack
uh but rugged g4 is a very difficult
move to play
especially if you don't remember or uh
something i'm pretty sure that
radha rajasthan had all prepared
but probably he just didn't remember so
that's why you know sometimes at this
level whenever
grandmasters prepare with engines
so well before the game sometimes such
details move number 20 or 25
pretty much decide the game because in
this position after queen e1
rook f6 route g4 uh rg6 through g4 was
the
key idea that held here for black but
radoswar e3 which is also very logical
to be
uh to be honest because e3 seems like it
opens the
king that some files for the rooks makes
this rook also
very active whether with the word lines
like burger single g6
this rook is already participating in
the game but simply tactically it
doesn't
it doesn't work uh d4 who this is not i
think good move because uh
again just regret six i think this will
be i think better version
uh but no we can just detect this pawn
uh we can simply take the pawn
uh we can take the pawn this will happen
in the game rook f6
so again idea of uh rfc which is always
there
and the king f2
you know we need king needs to run
pretty much from this g5 rich six again
threatening
ideas of g2 and so on but up it appears
that
simply knight d2 finally bring this uh
knight to the game and this is a big
difference uh with the previous position
uh whenever white hit pawn on d2 and
black point pawn on e4 i'll quickly go
back there
just to show what i meant what i mean
let's say
something like this right the position
of after vg4
unfortunately uh design on b1 cannot
quickly join the game here
it cannot quickly join the game
this knight is stuck there however
in this position as in the game knight
is already on d2
knight is already on d2 and this makes a
lot of
you know a lot of difference because
right now uh blacks to be very careful
to
pretty much make sure that this attack
uh you know is sufficient for equality
not talking about already being better
but just we're talking about the quality
and uh to be honest i don't think it
suffices anymore
so in the game of g2 king f3
and the knight g6 so of course
the the threat is like 95 right
and you know this king will be we'll go
for a walk
for a stroll around the all sort of
mating nets and stuff
so right now we need to whiten is to
prep
protect the kink so white plate uh e4
the idea is to basically have a free
square available in any instance
and after this point okay i think this
move uh you know e3
as in the as shown here wasn't it wasn't
accurate but still was quite okay
uh wasn't losing however here
after e4 i think uh uh
radek made a decisive mistake
he played a knight e5 and this is i
think a blunder that
pretty much loses so
the best way to play here was to play f4
i believe
the and and retain all the ideas
but at first to the control over the
square on
uh e3 the again the position is
obviously totally
crazy still as i think
you know is like engine play like engine
analysis right now and
all of this is you know very very
complicated
and i analyzed this and i think i
figured the way to somehow save this for
black
even though it's very complicated but
anyway i would like to share my uh
discovery not sure how
perhaps it could be improved somewhere
but at least at the first site
uh what i analyzed is somehow it seems
to work
however this requires of course huge
accuracy for both from both sides to
play
and what i'm gonna show right now is
pretty much just computer analysis that
i
that i performed but it pretty much
makes sense i'll try to explain what's
happening so the best move is queen h1
the person uh for wise play queen h1 and
attack on the rook on g2
hoping to basically capture it simplify
the position and enter some end game
whenever this king will be finally saved
because whenever it will be an end game
the king
should be safe so in this position black
has some
choice the best move is
i mean sorry one of the typical or
logical moves is to play insane at h4
but some doesn't work because king f4
and again
this king can simply finally get to a
free square so knight h4 doesn't work
another possibility is to play for
instance move
king h6 king h6 also makes
some sense to get this king out
of the g file because you know rook take
quinto h2 is a b sorry queen h2 is a big
threat
let's say black plays some round move
like rook b7 just waiting move
queen g2 and white pretty much wins
because right now knight h4 is not
possible because
king and knight are pinned so bishop
gtook inch 2 this endgame is obviously
winning for white
therefore the point is for black to
remove the king from the g
file in order to have knight h4
available let's say that's why king h6
makes sense
because the queen g2 knight h4
and to hope to get the
i mean to get queen in this way and play
no and then hope to save this this
position however
here i believe uh in this instance i
think white has some chances to win the
game king plays f4 knight takes g2
and the king g3 right now most pieces
are a little bit
shaky a bishop on h3 is under attack so
why could
black should play rg8 and of course king
h3 leads to a perpetual check with a
draw
king h49 g2 and just a draw
so white should not take the knight the
bishop i mean and y should play
king to f2 and here in this position we
have essentially
for instance uh after another four king
e3
um rook g1 i analyzed knight b3
rook f1 bishop d2 something like this
one example lines not only
it's not exclusive the you know also
some alternatives as well
however here after bishop d2
in this position in general white has
wise exchange down but has two pawns for
his exchange and
potentially those pawns are weak so and
and very importantly uh policies is very
advanced so if we can capture these guys
like this pulmonary systems may even
eventually become
a very strong pawn and also like a pair
of bishops which also
helps finally king is safe and white
king is safe
so it's also an important detail i think
white has some chances here
i think white is better in this position
that's why
i'm not i know this is what uh wojtek
was analyzing
probably something along those lines
uh but i think that after f4 queen h1
the best move is king f6 and this is
exactly the same idea like king h6 but
the difference is that
uh it is already thinking about the
future
uh assuming that queen you know
white will take winter eg2 and there
will be some end game
king blacking should be also you know in
the center already
so that's kind of like you know pretty
much
nearly inhuman to find over the board uh
things like that
anyway position just in human to achieve
without computer preparation
at first place so um yeah king f6 is
also you know very very difficult move
here analyze bunch of possibilities for
both sides
and uh i eventually concluded that uh
perhaps sorry not twin perhaps bishop b3
i guess
uh is the best um
uh chance or bishop we should be free
or uh yeah we should be fair queen
towards this was the best chance
like but again this analysis is totally
uh
crazy so after we should be free h5 uh
sorry bishop d5 uh you know rook to
g5 and to be honest i
myself have harder understanding what's
going on here
it's just at this point it's just
memorization try not to plunder ahead
one move at the time
this type of chess you know this
variation leads to
so um after rook g5
white uh you know
position is just great after king f2
let's say 95
you know white all black always has some
initiative but probably with correct
play if the game should end with draw
friends after
c4 rule g2 take stakes and finally take
here and enter some end game like this
uh with
probable probable pro draw
anyway this was of course probably the
best play
for for black and still with chances to
make a draw
and of course queen g2 this is already a
worst version of king on h6 because
after
another h4 king f4 knight g2 king g3
uh rook g8 of course king h3 again is
just a draw
and king g5 kingshua will lead very
likely to
only prop trouble rather than you know
for four white
so after king f2
right now black can play knight h4 and
the difference is that this king is on
f6 not on h6 so knight h4 is possible
if king on h6 there will be knight f3
and uh for instance right here
however king is on f6 and the white
black versus g2
invade and with with sufficient
counterplay essentially
so uh therefore this was this was linked
to
you know a draw so f4 this move was
pretty much
only way to survive here only way to
survive here with
black another queen h1 very difficult
move king f6
um yeah and according to my analysis
basically dispersion holds for for black
so let's see what happened in the game
after e4
uh voyager played uh
king 95 now king e3 king goes
you know king escapes pretty much and it
is
already uh too
[Music]
too late it's terrific why is winning
after f4 king takes the f4
knight g4 uh very important move e5
e5 the point is of e52 again
as earlier we played e4 to get e3 square
for the king now we play e5
e5 to obtain e4 square for the king in
case of a check on f8 or something like
that
and the king pretty much escapes and the
game the rest of the game is just
over because knight takes e5 allows
white to play queen takes e5 rooktace v5
king takes e5
and after root is h2 we enter this end
game where essentially again pawn on c6
is deciding factor
even 4.1 c6 i think the game will be
very close to
a draw but with pawn on c6 so being so
advanced
and the voice pawns being weak on h67
i think white is simply uh simply
winning
so uh bishop e4 uh
you know the rest is pretty much a very
nice technique here by
uh miranda so we let's let's see how he
won
uh knight f3 uh bishop g2 king d4
uh rook f2 now knight g5
makes sense to drive those knights sorry
for bishops
and simplify the position a little bit
and then attack those pawns on c7 and a6
with the knight and bishop
so knight bishop takes knight takes
hitting the rook
rook f1 bishop to g5 bishop goes to d8
potentially at some point
of course not immediately because of d1
right so uh into
some small caution is required uh bishop
b7 is very accurate
h5 trying to look for control with the
pawn on h
upon the king side try to run with it
forward but
right now knight c5 0 but not a6
this is simply winning a5 followed pawn
takes
h4 trying to push this pawn forward as
quickly as possible but this is
not uh sufficient because bishop takes
h4
f4 king d5 uh rook takes h4 and this
this pawn and this end game is simply
winning because of
a6 and white is pretty much
on time to to promote the pawn to the
queen because
the black skin is simply too far away
and this
is winning for uh for white so in the
game happen king f7
a7 rook h8 now
uh knight a6
hitting spawn on c7 yes white is losing
pawn a7
but we import seven and again as i was
saying earlier pawn
the c6 phone is the keypad and
simply there is no way to stop it
basically c7 next and the game is over
no after pretty much anything even after
rook a5 which was what happened in the
game
uh right now c7 wins uh c7
and after b5 i i've okay
and notation such as there was king e4
of course i think was because white
wants to
you know players put kings on e4 and d5
to put those
kings you know in the center to claim
the white win winning the game
so uh of but of course had to be played
king d4 or king c4 or
involve both moves pretty much win on
the spot or kingdom six even wins as
well but knee four queens for other
are the easiest so uh
yes so this is the game that i want to
talk about
[Music]
miranda versus voitasha very interesting
game
very interesting game big theoretical
fight in the opening and uh eventually
uh you know success miranda was
successful uh
to win uh to use his preparation and win
the game
convincingly uh personally i'm happy
that
the the the variation that i analyzed
for the book was
used by you know very strong
grandmasters
so this makes me you know personally
happy that you know
i could see this variation appear on the
board
and actually after later saying that
after
you know reading some or maybe not
entire book but let's say
part of this book that i you know that i
wrote
what is the best way to avoid this risky
version for black
the best way is to avoid this
variation for black is not to play
bishop c5 because if you play bishop c5
you
essentially agree to enter this line
and this pretty much is the best way to
play with black uh whatever happened in
the game so if you want to play
different type of roy lopez for instance
bishop b7 or maybe b5 bishop c5 if you
are playing a bishop c5
those are the ways to go because if you
play bishop c5 right away
then c3 b5 bishop c2 there is
pretty much no way to not to play
d4 uh not play like for not to enter
this line
so uh that's pretty much
what i think is going on like exa all
this all those moves
you know are uh premier league maybe not
forced but nearly fours of course there
are alternatives as well here let's see
like bishop g
uh g4 i mean it's one move but there
also moves like i think short castle i
think there
is also take on f3 you can try these
moves
but i think the position is crazy either
way
and very risky for black so therefore i
would uh
probably suggest to play other line like
b5 bishop c5
oh come on why can't i move uh yeah p5
and bishop c5 if you want to go for
something similar or
um or in this position
uh to play you know like bishop b7 for
instance which is the classical or even
opens
open spanish for knight to c4 pretty
much all of them are covering the book
as well
um okay i hope this uh this makes sense
and it helps
so uh just give me a second guys i'm
gonna
because we're still like 50 minutes i
think maybe we'll not cover entire
uh entire uh
game again
of you know the second game they
prepared but pretty much uh
we'll cover a little bit and i think
probably
i'll skim through some of the parts but
i will
show the most most interesting moments
from
uh from the game that next i want to
show
so the next game i prepared is the game
uh of also verado tashack but this time
against
bartoszochiko so
this game actually runs from watashi one
he won in 28 moves
he won 28 moves i think 20 maybe yeah 28
moves yes i remember correctly
so this was very good game by radek
and he showed this time very very
strong and good preparation here with
white pieces as well
so let's see what happened d4 knight f6
c4
e6 g3 so this is uh invitation to
catalan
invitation catalan after d5
will be probably g2 and with the catalan
however
strategically decided to play c5
which allows uh to play allows white to
play d5 which transfers to benoni
so uh it takes e5 c takes d5 uh
oh hello hello ian
[Music]
kinky is a positive anything for the
greetings
d6 knight c3 g6 bishop g2 bishop g7
the the idea let me go back is
i lost focus for a second here the idea
uh to play c5
is to enter benoni pretty much enter
bononi but with already g3 being played
on the board
because in benoni white has generally so
many
options good options to
obtain some promising position
for instance i can maybe show here like
neither three for instance uh c
or maybe i should play saying that c for
nice c3 let's say c5 d5 takes takes d6
right now in this position white has
number of ways to
uh to play this number of setups for
instance one setup is knight f3
uh bishop f4 one another setup
or maybe we should put it g6 bishop f4
is one possibility
other possibilities to play uh e4 g6
and now uh knight e2 knight g3
it's also possible to play uh bishop d3
knight e2
there's also classical plans uh oh hold
on why can i move this
how can i remove the okay now
um also there is setup to play f3 and
transpose to
uh benoni with f3 which is very
which also appears from um
zamasu variation in king's india other
possibilities go to simply for classical
stuff like knight f3 bishop g7 bishop e2
shortcast knight d2 for example another
possibility is to play with f4
bishop g7 bishop b5 which is very crazy
and
concrete and dynamic variation so
all of those possibilities are there and
what to
and apart from that there is also move
g3 so
if white starts with move g3
the the key is that if c5 and we have
bennoni
the white is already committed to play
you know
bononi with g3 which you know if you are
a banony player
it reduces pretty much what you have to
learn right
so this is uh
you know this is the basically black's
idea here so again for it takes d5
takes d5 uh d6 knight c3 g6 bishop g2
this is all theory
g7 knight f3 a short castle short castle
rook e8 um i think this is the main move
right now there is quite a big theory of
course in
number of ways uh what has many moves
for some it doesn't i think
what was it 2012
i believe i played myself here 92 and
against yuri krivaruchko
and i won very nice game with white
however the theory suggests
nowadays that this is just uh just equal
uh you know why black and black can have
a good game in number of ways
um bishop f4 is the most
testing i believe or let's say the no no
no the most tasty but the most popular
probably also the most testing me back
but you know you can try to look for yes
pretty much anywhere
but radius for watching play movie one
which is also
popular lately and i also played myself
uh
in 2002 not 20 2019
2019 against ilya smirin
in saint louis winter classic i think it
was or
no it was winter classic i believe san
luis winter classic
um one of those classics and
i i think i had very good chances at
some point but
then i was under pressure as well so it
was very
double-edged game very interesting
eventually and it ended up being a draw
so uh what is it
so okay rookie what happened in the game
uh right now uh part of social play move
knight a6
so i think 96 is a little bit inaccurate
i think personally the knight
knight bd7 or a6 and 9bd7 uh
say a6 a4 knight bd7 is the way to go
one of these two
however 96 i think is a kind of like
of course possible many players play
like play play this move
but i think it's a little bit inaccurate
in my opinion and be precisely because
of what uh
radiation played bishop f4
after bishop f4 there's okay
there again number of moves for black
and four white as well
but in general the the point is that
let me go back for a second after bishop
f4 94 is considered as really good
and if white plays rookie one knight a6
now bishop f4
knight d4 is not that good by some
reason inclusion of moves look look e1
and knight
a6 makes a huge difference in the
evaluation of this position
and we'll see in a second uh what what
what is makes the difference but first
let's look at this line
of knight 94 because the point is after
this this this
in id2 of course the rook goes back
knight c4 is simply
a huge advantage for y because there's
there are certain issues pawn on d6
so black has to sacrifice the exchange
and shoot plays b2 rook b1 bishop g7
and the point is in general is very
often this knight has a possibility
and choice were to go over to a6 or to
d7
whenever it needs to go to e7 it goes to
d7 and stops e5 ideas let's say e4
sorry e45 ideas but if you can already
see
that if this the same thing happens with
this pawn on uh
sorry not this uh with the same thing
happens here after knight d4
with the inclusion of rookie 1 and 96
it's already way different way
way different story because uh in the
same
in the same position white already
played rook e1
which supports e4 e5 while knight island
a6 is already
kind of could be misplaced because it
has no option to go to d7
so that's the pretty much the general
difference in my opinion
so uh knight if probably better move was
like bishop g4 maybe or maybe
like bishop f5 but
you know it's been a wise analysis so uh
i just know that 94 is going to consider
as the best move
but anyway i think in general uh because
of 96 bishop f4 with the inclusion of
this rookie one move white can hope for
some advantage here
but um okay in the game for 94 and
knight takes e4 rook to c4 knight d2
rook takes the f4 sacrificing the
exchange correct take stakes rook b1
bishop g7 so we got this position right
similar to the one we talked about
earlier like this one but the difference
is
that is the inclusion of the most rookie
one and knight a6
so let's go back there
and uh right now it's clear that uh
white's this is i think this is clear
that this
is advantageous to white because white
can play e4 very quickly and
play move e5 where it's very quickly
support this uh
e45 idea uh while in the other variation
there was possibility to play knight
seven and somehow
resist this idea of e5 right now the
knight on e6 is misplaced
therefore i think white has very good
chances and it was very good preparation
here by
radek and basically because of that i
think bartosz lost this game
because
right now this position already looks
very suspicious to me
so um
okay so uh in this position
part barthological played move knight to
b4 trying to activate this knight
which is of course uh very logical uh
trying to you know activate pieces and
jump with this knight to
you know d3 square and this would be a
great idea
uh if only it uh worked unfortunately
there is some certain uh problem uh
that you know this list is nice to be
simply misplaced
so but anyway position is already very
very risky
so potentially
maybe it was better to play like rook b8
or maybe play bishop
value of b5 uh let me just put it on the
board
let's say uh maybe rook b85 or b5 maybe
or play move like bishop h6 changes pawn
at least
but anyway after bishop h6 for example
uh i think white has very strong attack
after or initiative after e5 bishop f4
and now
e6 so this position probably is
just very very bad for for black because
both pawns are just so advanced and
they stop the development of those this
bishop once here in rural a8
so if and if that's the case well
um you know it does simply doesn't look
good
if black and black brings from space to
the game but okay knight before
tries to activate this bishop but the
design at least so it is logical of
course but
it still uh doesn't really solve
problems
uh rook b8 followed by b5 also made some
sense
however uh after you know sorry
the root b8 value of b5 takes makes some
sense as well
makes some sense as well but again just
e5 is
always always a problem so uh i just
think that in this position after e4
is already a huge advantage to to rather
foreign
so after knight before uh rook b3 i
think was a very
neat move because stops 93 idea and
ignores pawn a2
[Music]
and yeah pretty much stops is very good
prophylactical idea
e5 comes next so knight xa2
a fallout but uh you know after knight
takes a2 this knight is also
misplaced however of course the idea is
to bring this
way to the game of knight c3 or you know
or something like that
so again we should just continue our
plan with white play move e5
and e5 leads to obviously uh
great uh problems for black and
as i checked with the engine this is
already you know winning for white
which is surprising because i mean on
one hand it's surprising
that move number 17 and what is already
you know winning
but on the other hand perfectly makes
sense because
of the this enable this bad knight on a6
that's why you should try to in such
structures like benoni
especially in such lines with um
you know such sharp lines like you know
uh with this exchange sacrifice
it is very uh
i don't know how to put it but like it's
very complicated and you need to be very
careful how you put your pieces
into kind of like just try to
uh not be guessing it of course but try
to you know assess correctly
which is of course comes with experience
comes with uh let's say knowledge of the
position
and and but in homework analysis that's
why it's you know in general who works
more or just
than sends those positions better right
um
okay anyway e5 uh
very strong move now uh knight b4 knight
comes back
but is of course logical but again
the same ideas earlier with this night
bishop h6 bishop before
where white played move e6 basically
both pawns are just dominating here and
white has huge huge attack and
technically what is just winning the
rest of the game is pretty much
a very nice technique and
you know powerful play by uh radek who
convincingly
won this game and with it the first game
of
their uh some of us are my final match
in polish championships
so let's see what happened uh e6
simply the queen e7 but again
just push the pawns forward weaken the
king side f5 very logical
uh pawn takes knight c4 right now rook
can swing always to the kings of through
g3
and yeah the rest of the game is pretty
much uh
you know you're you know like not
irrelevant but like
it's very difficult for black to make
any anything out of it and
uh radix without going basically one so
let's see how it happened
pawn takes one takes wish up takes
simply rookie free this pin is
just very very annoying queen h4
at least trying to get this knight on c4
but
uh knight d6 again this king is just so
so weak it's basically no way
for black to salvage this unfortunately
so rook f7 so bishop f7
happened the game simply takes takes and
the
no queen d7 the fact that you know black
has
you know like three extra pawns for for
i mean three pawns for the exchange
it's totally relevant because what
matters the most is the king safety
and this king is simply too exposed to
be defended so the queen d7 king g8
rook to g3 uh queen f6 and finally
a final piece joins the attack rugby
seven and here part of sachiko resigned
uh and radek won a very very nice game
so okay this is pretty much all i
prepare for today
[Music]
i hope it was interesting especially uh
i mean
the opening in this one i'm pretty much
both openings in this one
and the previous game i think
both was lots of powerful and
combinative play in both games
so i hope you guys enjoyed it
so thank you for today thanks for
watching and
i will see you next time bye have a good
one